je pense qu'en tant que civilisation il
faudrait peut-être qu'on grandisse un
petit peu parce que la beauté se les
faire minimum vous avez fait remise
bagnolet la beauté par définition cyril
c'est moins sur lesquels on y peut
strictement rien c'est ça c'est vrai
objectif donc c'est la définition même
de l'injustice c'est à dire que tu es né
comme ça t'es pas né comme ça tu ne peux
rien y faire
tu peux être canon est la plus de la
plus grande ordure sur terre tu es quand
même canon tu peux être plus tôt selon
les collègues envahir nos codes
collectif plutôt plus moche
robin est donc voilà donc je trouve que
finalement quand on dit finalement sur
la place du village les gens se
rassemblent parce que ça fait plaisir de
gagner ça ben c'est un peu la victoire
de quand on n'a plus rien quoi quand on
n'a plus rien en tant que femme
ben on à son corps on à son look et cima
si je pense qu'on a tous vécu par les
familles l'a pas oublié il faudrait déjà
porté plainte à walt disney déjà parce
qu'il me met toujours une image avec
cendrillon qui a une taille de guêpe en
passe de rentrer ça dans la mairie je
pense que vous réalisez comme et
attendez je pense j'ai pas dit que vous
avez des enfants
moi j'ai trois ibom alors ma fille a
toujours rêvé d'être miss france bon
maintenant elle a changé
je pense que quand même vous réalisez la
ne s'est pas la peine de me dire on va
porter plainte contre 10 n'est pas ce
que c'est sa part m haies ont
abusivement on va dire eh ben oui on
dirait on si deezer le sujet le sujet
c'est de savoir c'est ce qu'ont à nous
même et y compris nous les femmes
le recul suffisant pour comprendre que
dans la société il ya des choses à
profonde à l'oeuvre qui nous qui nous
qui nous place nous les femmes un
certain endroit qui l'on doit d'être la
potiche joly c'est que les élégies odile
mais hélas doudou excusé à son idée liée
qui est présidente du comité miss france
on a marqué à leurs fins
cliquez qui geneviève de fontenay genève